[Music]  the senate judiciary committee held a  confirmation hearing for supreme court  nominee judge kataji brown jackson but  the memories of the brett kavanaugh and  amy coney barrett hearings linger  it's been 17 years since a democrat on  the senate judiciary committee voted for  a republican nominee for the supreme  court  and other than senator lindsey graham  it's been that long since a republican  on the committee voted for a democrat  nominee for the high court 17 years  so what's the purpose of these hearings  if it's going to be a straight  party-line vote regardless are these  hearings educational helpful  constructive  is this what advice and consent was  meant to be hey sean hannity here hey  click here to subscribe to fox news  youtube page and catch our hottest  interviews and most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else